21 million americans are addicted to
drugs or alcohol president trump this
month called the opioid epidemic a
national emergency the cover story of
september's national geographic looks
into the science of addiction and its
impact on the brain's pathways author
fran smith writes this addiction remolds
neural circuits to assign supreme value
to cocaine or heroin or gen at the
expense of other interests such as
health work family or life itself fran
smith joins us at the table to discuss
hello fran very good to see you i think
when most people think of addicts they
don't think you know what they got brain
issues but you're saying the brain plays
a very big role here how the brain plays
a huge role
addiction causes hundreds of changes in
the structure of the brain and the
chemistry of the brain in the pathways
that send nerve signals so that cells
communicate with each other and the the
it's very complicated but this but the
basic
essence of it is that it remaps the
brain and it causes the brain to focus
on this one thing one thing only that
object of desire and blot out other
things of interest so i think of it kind
of like a zoom lens on a camera you're
focusing on this one thing and
everything else is out of view and at
the same time the brain
changes your ability to to put the lid
on design this kind of thinking start
friend because back in the 70s when
there when the addiction was affecting
the black community in the inner city
community they were just cast aside as
junkies addicts it was seen as a moral
failing and now that it's become more
pronounced in other communities now we
hear it's a disease when did that change
and how did that change well the medical
community has recognized it as a disease
for a long time law enforcement is
starting to come around i was just in
huntington west virginia which has been
hit really hard and talked with the
former police chief and he said we are
not going to arrest our way out of this
problem what really changed it not only
is the opioid epidemic has really opened
up people's eyes to the to the problem
but
the
um the technology in the 19 back in the
70s when heroin was was a real problem
in in the inner cities we didn't have
brain scanners nobody knew what was
going on inside the given that do you
think we'll see an addiction vaccine in
our lifetime well there is work on
addiction vaccine there have been a
number of studies
there have been some promising results
but nothing immediately on the horizon
but some of the things that have been
helpful include cognitive therapy right
how can we retrain the brain after being
addicted to drugs or alcohol right
cognitive therapy has shown really great
effects for lots of people and it really
trains people how to think differently
about
about drugs and alcohol and and and you
can see in in brain scanning studies
that it really does begin to change how
those circuits are operating rewiring
the brain in us are some people more
prone to addiction than others
people are there are genetic aspects to
addiction there's no nobody has
identified a gene or a or an addictive
personality one thing that we know is
that
kids adolescents are really vulnerable
and that so many people who have
addiction later in life really began
misusing drugs or alcohol as teens or
young adults adolescent brain is still
very very vulnerable it's not fully
formed exactly yeah well your article is
very very good it's very well done a lot
of good information there thank you very
much thank you smith